- [Announcer] Hello and welcome
to "The Kelly Clarkson Show."
Give it up for today's
celebrity host, Sunita Mani!
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- Hi.
Hello.
Welcome to "The Kelly Clarkson Show."
(Sunita laughs)
No, you are not seeing things.
I am, in fact, not Kelly.
(audience laughs)
She's not feeling great today.
So it's me, Sunita Mani, to the rescue.
(audience cheering)
(Sunita laughs)
I've always wanted to host a show,
and with my new movie
"Spirited," in theaters,
and just starting to stream on Apple TV+,
it seems like the perfect timing, right?
(audience cheering)
And it's not just me,
it's a full cast takeover,
with Ryan Reynolds,
Will Ferrell,
(audience cheering)
and Octavia Spencer.
But first, this show
always starts with music.
And since I unfortunately
can't do Kelly-level vocals,
I'm leaving it to the pro
with a Kellyoke Encore.
Here's Kelly and her band, Y'all,
along with the Southern
California Trojan Marching Band,
with "Seven Nation Army"
by the White Stripes.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat rock music)
♪ I'm gonna fight 'em all ♪
♪ A seven nation army
couldn't hold me back ♪
♪ They're gonna rip it off ♪
♪ Taking their time right behind my back ♪
♪ And I'm talking to myself at night ♪
♪ Because I can't forget ♪
♪ Back and forth through my mind ♪
♪ Behind a cigarette ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ And the message coming from my eyes ♪
♪ Says, Leave it alone ♪
♪ Leave it alone ♪
♪ I'm going to Wichita ♪
♪ Far from this opera forevermore ♪
♪ I'm gonna work the straw ♪
♪ Make the sweat drip out of every pore ♪
♪ And I'm bleeding, and I'm
bleeding, and I'm bleeding ♪
♪ Right before the Lord ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ All the words are gonna bleed from me ♪
♪ And I will sing no more ♪
♪ And the stains coming from my blood ♪
♪ Tell me, Go back home ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ Go back home ♪
- One more time,
give it up for Kelly and her band, Y'all,
(audience cheering)
along with the University
of Southern California
Trojan marching band.
(audience cheering)